[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week at the roundtable of
dim lighting we're asking the question
if you were a boat what type of boat
would you be
and this might strike you as an odd
question maybe you've thought about this
before we actually got I've never
thought we got this question from mr.
Alex punch who has moved on to bigger
and better things still remains good
friends he actually stopped by today he
didn't tell me he was gonna be here
mythical crew member emeritus yeah so
call him that so we're happy for Alex as
he he had a great opportunity working
for somebody it's not me sorry once he
told me he had an opportunity and I was
Annie and we heard about the specifics I
was like okay well I don't remember no
I'm not gonna promote his company we
well we wish him well we wish him what
we wish him well we love him and we're
using one of his ideas for this podcast
he actually this is an idea that he
actually pitched for a new biscuit he
said that his mother was a child
therapist she said he said counselor I
think maybe therapist too you know
something along those lines and this is
a question that she gets the children
that she works with to ask an answer and
if it's if we've proven anything if
something's good enough for children
it's good enough for man children yeah
good enough for children good enough for
man children so really this was really I
mean it was basically it was an idea
conceived by Alex's mom along with Alex
conceived by Z it's probably inside the
way it's probably in some sort of book
or something that she studied let's just
say we came up with it wouldn't cut
everything okay all right we came up
with this question we got this idea that
we think will be good for child
counselors and therapists what kind of
boat would you be if you could be but
because it gives insight into how you
view your own self self your personhood
and personality what we're gonna answer
the question for each other into that
we're gonna answer the the question for
each other as well we're gonna guess
which boat
I'm not I'm not trying to guess which
boat you described yourself as I'm just
describing my thought was described what
boat I thought you were and you may or
may not agree yeah I can tell me what
boat you are and vice versa I know what
boat I think I am and I know what boat I
think you are which I totally think is
the boat that you think you are and I
would be but we are gonna talk about the
different types of boats and so my
answers may change but as it stands
right now just with my limited knowledge
of boats that coming into this I'm not
I'm not a boat master you know I like to
think of myself as a Waterman but I've
only been in a few bullets what is a
Waterman it's just a man of the water
and you think of yourself that way you
think of yourself as a man of the water
yeah like my heritage you know though
those those those Scots up on the locks
you know crossing the locks and swimming
and boating and Vikings pillaging
villages but not really doing that
personally because I get a little
seasick you know I think of myself as a
soil man yeah like a man of the soil you
know I think that you're in last name we
talked about this at some point I think
that your name Neil means to like Neil
and plant a seed man I don't know what
it leads but studying it and caresses
the soil I think it means I think it's a
farming thing I do think it is a farming
thing yeah you know a man of the soil
man of the water waters got to have soil
so he's gotta have water so you have mud
that's why would a muddy the muddy boys
with a muddy boys okay boys it's the
muddy boys um but we should talk about
yesterday cuz um yesterday was was
technically a workday yet speaking of
child therapy we didn't um took
advantage of took advantage of time that
we rarely have to not come into the
office and also red alert not really
work that much let last like coming back
from Thanksgiving break I looked at the
whole calendar year for 2019 and I was
like I want to go ahead and put all the
stuff on the counter that we know about
like we're doing a lot of touring stuff
we're shooting a lot of GMM of course I
wanted
I want to know every day in 2019 that
we're shooting anything and obligated
his stuff and I want to put blackout
dates like the like the credit card
companies do or like Disney does when
you buy an annual pass so right Jenna
and I worked very hard on this calendar
okay so that blacked out Monday was
months old
that's from Thanksgiving last year yeah
well I guess I didn't tell you because
if Sunday night my wife was you know
yeah with Jessie she was hanging out
what are you working tomorrow I was like
yeah she said well links not and he was
looking she was with me and she was like
I was like listen don't you're gonna
tell me they don't put me in the middle
of this it's on the calendar yeah but
it's on this special Lincoln jennacalee
but it's a money were invited to it's a
Monday though they just yeah yeah but
after tour I'm I'm not anyway no I'm
glad I'm glad I didn't come cuz watch
out buying that annual pass look at the
blackout dates first you show up at a
Disney and you turn you away but no you
have to pay you have to drop one
thousand quid to get in there so we had
a day with her I mean I had it I had a
day with Shepherd my youngest you had a
day with what me and Christie hung out
and then it'll well I mean Christian
we're gonna hang out and do some stuff
and the mail are really piled up but
then Lily was sick she called and had to
come home from school I was like well
now you gotta go get her and now I gotta
figure this out and I gotta I'm gonna do
a little bit of work and so then but
then I picked up Lando and then I picked
up Lincoln from school it's just like
well it just feels great to pick up a
kid from school it feels like I'm dad
him so hard
look at me driving up getting the car
kid I'm gonna I'm gonna be banging some
Chicago blast in Chicago I'm not banging
Chicago sounds like I'm having sex with
the band Chicago yeah which I've never
been given that opportunities like more
today what I would do or the city of
Chicago I'm sure there's a place there's
some area you could find
blasting did you blast it for real a
blast yeah so like with the windows
rolled down so you trying to embarrass
your kids not with the windows were now
but when he opened the door to get in it
just spilled out Chicago just blew out
like the Windy City and what was there a
quick shot of the door or was there an
embarrassment Lincoln doesn't do that
Lily's the one to do that and Lando for
totally different reasons like I don't
know I won't get into that but they both
have their reasons but you know the
middle child he just goes with the flow
man what else hmm and I he gets in the
car and he's like oh you got the bikes
on the back how you I'm using your bike
rack a lot thank you for that yeah you
haven't brought it back I keep using it
somebody's got to use it well I I bought
Lincoln a mountain bike to use it but
Lincoln well just call me I really in my
house and then or get your own well I
already have yours I really didn't want
to talk about this because I didn't want
it to come to this but because you knew
that it would it's mine now no that's
bike racks fine
it's it's you make a choice and buy it
because it works great yeah like it's
the best right highest rated you should
get another one for your house and then
I'll sell it to you for the price of a
new one I already have one yeah you're
gonna buy me a new one
so I put I actually bought myself a new
bike and I gave Lincoln my old bike
because I got a bigger wind and you got
it you got a new mountain bike I did
yeah when did win this happen I got a
29er
when I borrowed the the thing from you
like two months ago yeah sharks in the
front and back do it no I only got him
in the front because the my old bike
which Lincoln was going to ride is a
hardtail and I didn't want him looking
at my bike and have any excuse for white
doesn't want to ride with me oh so
mine's a hardtail and I said he's like
oh you got the bikes on the back I was
like yeah remember I told you I was
gonna pick you up from school we're
gonna go buy caning he knows I can't
tell if Lincoln's into it yet or if he
knows that I'm so into it that he's just
being very polite and so he doesn't put
up a fight
so we we went and we were biking on this
on this single track and it's I picked
something that wasn't too ambitious
because I don't want to burn him the
thing is the last couple of times we've
been out I've taken Lando too and I was
very delinquent in teaching Lando to
ride a bike like literally I taught him
to ride a bike three months ago so you
can't he's not gonna go up and down any
Hills with that situation but then that
bike was too small so then I had to buy
him a bike and the only place in town
had these like they were like mountain
bikes and I was like so he went from
learning to ride a bike to a week later
like riding a mountain bike but he did
that's the key don't try to teach you
you parents out there don't try to teach
your kids at a young age to do anything
wait until they can basically figure it
out on their own and then take all the
credit that's not my son he learned how
to ride a bike in ten minutes and two
weeks later he was on a mountain bike
in the woods because of me waiting until
he was way too old to learn how to do it
do it that goes for reading that goes
for math that goes for this is
questionable
a mini level it goes for like
relationships don't talk don't have open
communication with your kids about
anything until it's basically too late
and then you can take all the credit for
how they're growing how they're doing
everything perfectly yeah this is kind
of fizzling out yeah I'm a soil man it's
right you know it's it's different from
me then in most people but I will say we
get out of the single track and he's I
was like Lincoln you go in front of me
that way you can set the pace I could
keep an eye on you I can bark orders to
you like shift down shift up like just
coaching no coaching you call it you got
to learn how to mountain bike from the
back if you if you're in the front and
you're yelling you can't be hard hmm cuz
all of the sound fires forward down the
trail there's horses on this trail I
wanted him to go first in case he was
gonna like run up and it took us up a
horse that ain't gonna be me
get a handlebar and a horse took us so
is he it
what kind of we're not talking to going
up and down steep grades a little bit
yeah he's fine with this
he's afraid I took what I was saying was
I took Lando out on this trail a few
days earlier I always get so ambitious
and I scare my kids off and like Lando
is like basically huffing and puffing
and like breaking down in tears and
saying dad you lied to me you said this
is gonna be flat and I'm like you like
Lando you're right I'm sorry we can turn
around right now I'm just trying to like
patch it up because I don't want to I
don't want to turn him off from you know
this my passion mountain biking is your
passion it was my passion I lost it I'm
trying to regain it with my boys with my
children oh wait Lily - but she's not it
she's not she's not up for it
hmm so we had to turn around I'm like
Lincoln we're gonna come back just me
and you were gonna blaze this trail
without that the loser kid and all I
mean by loser kid is the one that we
keep kept losing okay I love him he's
not a loser but we kept losing him so
doesn't that make him a loser that makes
me a loser on two levels that's true so
we went back and we're on this trail and
he's going Lincoln's going ahead of me
and I just I had a moment that I was
like a moment of dad gratitude the
gratitude and I was like this is it
dream come true like literally I've been
well not dreaming but I've been like
daydreaming about this moment where I'm
like mountain biking on a single track
with my own progeny what specifically
happened nothing we just rode the bikes
oh I thought like his like his helmet
got in front of the Sun or something you
thought I was building out to a story
that happened man a moment of gratitude
like I mean just you know you and your
boy doing something yeah I had a crepe
with my boy yeah crepe did you have a
gratitude moment
what a crepe I had an excellent day with
Shepherd I mean we really had a good
time we we got lunch together he he's
got he has a crepe problem if there's a
crepe on the menu he will order it how's
that a problem
well yeah I would I would say it's a
borderline addiction to crepes
but you know there's a lot worse things
to be addicted to is he like stealing
money from your wallet and you're like
what are you doing you're like what you
like bust in the room and he's like I
learned it from you dad I saw you eat a
thin pancake I'm scraping together
scratch for a crepe we we split the
crepe you know we each had a sandwich we
split the crepe having a great
discussion we've each got a you in Paris
no just you know they serve crepes at us
establishments cool although this was a
French bakery and then we went to a park
that has just all kinds of things going
on and so we each took a book and that
was like Shepherd you have a book that
you could read because it was a
beautiful day we're gonna walk around
with a little full day we're gonna find
a bench wasn't it the perfect day yeah
and do some bench reading you know screw
mountain biking when you can read on a
bench a bench is like a mountain bike
that doesn't move can't get hurt on a
bench
I hadn't proved you wrong there but so
we go and we and Shepherd has in mind
this is a large area and there's all
kinds of stuff at this at this place and
he has a map and he's like I'm letting
him lead and he's like you know he's
having a lot of fun and he's like we
need to find a desolate bench I was like
I'm I'm on Team desolate bench he said
desolate Bay I'm completely on board he
said there's lots eleven years old right
10 he's like there's a lot of people
here desolate and we need to find a
desolate we need to go to the most
desolate place so we go to a desolate
place and I'm like ok this is cool we're
talking we're you know making
observations about the natural world it
would begin reading and then as soon as
we get down like we we read like two
pages on our books and then Shepherds
like
got to get some water and he's like dad
would you let me use the map to map tool
to a water fountain well I didn't come
back there's quite a park it's got his
own mind I was like yeah go for it
independence I value that I'm a
proponent of it he goes and then really
the idea wasn't to get water it was to
go away and then try to sneak up on me
oh you wanted and so he's got that gene
yeah and so like I'm in the water I'm
sitting there reading and I'm like and
just what I mean by that his Rhett would
do that a lot to me
where is where is where is shepper and I
just kind of looked and he was like 10
feet behind me sneaking up on me he's
like just in the open yeah and then
repeatedly he would leave and continue
to sneak up on haha and I called him
every time you gotta catch him every
time and then he was like he let him
slip up why can you hear me and it was
like Shepherd I know where you're at at
all times this is an opportunity to me
feel like he's he can't escape my watch
this is this is this has given him the
God but then one of the one of the
things he's like dad there is a he says
look at these secret in in a little map
it was like find our hidden spots
there's a large multi acre acre
situation and he was like find our
hidden spots there is a Fibonacci he
couldn't say it was like there's a
Fibonacci spiral of rock somewhere in
this particular forest let's go find it
mm-hmm so we start looking for the for
the Fibonacci spiral and we didn't find
it and because and ironically we
probably should have done a Fibonacci
sequence search pattern in order to find
the Fibonacci sequence but we didn't do
that and we ran out of time I had to go
pick out live from school anyway had an
incredible time with chef still
undiscovered he kept saying I'm having
so much fun this is great we're on an
adventure that's awesome so I had ad ad
ad ad ad ad data tude dad it no I didn't
have it headed gratitude did do
gratitude but let me say just one
thing here say it and I'm a little bit
embarrassed by this as someone who has
an engineering degree and has a lot of
mathematical experience I could have
picked out a Fibonacci sequence and like
if you gave me like four images I could
have picked the one that was a Fibonacci
sequence probably because I'm like
Brennan's heart got it tattooed on his
forearm and other it looks like a snail
yes yell right right but I did not I
could not have defined what a Fibonacci
sequence is and maybe you're in the same
boat
speaking of transitions to what we're
gonna talk about next but a Fibonacci
sequence is this fascinating thing I'm
in fact I actually think I actually
ordered a book all about it because I'm
so fascinated by it and I'd heard about
it people talk about the golden ratio
but I was always like I don't really
know what that is and I'm not gonna look
it up but essentially Fibonacci sequence
is starting from the number zero and one
and then continuing in a sequence where
the next number is the sum of the
previous two numbers so you got zero and
then one in the next number is zero plus
1 which is 1 the next number is 1 plus 1
which is 2 and then 2 plus 1 which is 3
and then 5 and then 8 and then 13 and
then 21 and yet continues to add up like
that and then if you take the way you
get that pattern is if you take squares
that the length of the the side of the
squares is the number in the Fibonacci
sequence and you continue to connect the
corners of the squares with the next
biggest one it goes out like this and it
creates like a snail pattern viral a
spiral that's very recognizable pattern
but then if you take any two numbers in
the Fibonacci sequence the number and
then the number before it and you divide
the number before it by the number after
it you get this number called Phi which
you know we know pi is a very popular
mathematical number of a Phi is like
1.618 something and that's constant
that's the golden ratio and you see it
all the time in nature but also there's
many like people have made sculptures
who were like I want the proportions of
someone's face the the proportions of
the link to the width of their faiths
face to be one to be Phi and you see it
in
Hank Green's got an old scishow video we
kind of like three minutes kind of
explains it and talks about the the
patterns and how you see these numbers
in the sequence show up in nature all
the time like flowers are usually and
have petals of you know 3 5 8 13 21 and
all it shows up in all these places in
nature and it seems like some magic
thing but really it's just it's the most
efficient way to like pack things into
different patterns anyway you should
super exciting you should talk to my
wife more about that she's really into
you know she's she was a math major she
was she was also told as she was in high
school that whatever she did with a
boyfriend that her grandma up in heaven
was watching her was her grandma
Fibonacci no it was just kind of like
when you told Shepherd that you're
always watching him so he stays in line
but I'm super excited to talk to
Shepherd about it now because it's like
now now my wife's grandma was watching
us watch me no not us she's sitting
right with it know whenever I'm with
Christie know whenever she's watching
know whenever you're with the band
Chicago that's know I could much when
she's watching my grandma's are still
living so they only watch me when I'm
there or video chat but I but I'm
legitimately like I'm like now it's
pretty crazy I'm ready to go back and
they find it I'm telling my the sequence
yeah but be explained to Shepherd like
this is actually this really cool
concept that shows up and I just felt do
you know what it made me think it made
me think that like I felt like I've been
missing out I was like why have I never
I've heard people talk about this and
why have I let it just wash over me 41
years old consider myself pretty curious
why have I let the reality of the
Fibonacci sequence to just wash over me
without ever just taking literally the
30 seconds to look at the wiki to figure
out what it is I understand the
sentiment but I'll just counter that by
saying also don't let don't let that
wash over you but also don't let and I'm
sure you didn't let the fact
Shepard told you especially more than
once that he was having a good time
because awesome the dad I mean we've
talked about this a lot like the goal of
daddy it's we operate under a lot of
times seems to be like I'm conducting
this thing and I want I want
acknowledgement and so the fact that you
got that that that's a big deal
and I actually think if you didn't you
should tell him something similar to
what I told Lincoln cuz I iced at
Lincoln down at the when we were coming
back from our ride
we're almost done we sat down on the
rocks and finished our water bottles and
I said I told Lincoln what I just told
you I was like you know when we first
started riding and you were riding ahead
of me I was thinking this is like a
dream come true for me
I just mean I've been thinking about us
being able to ride mountain bikes
together for like months and you know
there's a lot of logistics that had to
line up and this is very special and I
just said that and then there's we took
a picture and I left it that I wasn't
asking for a response or anything but
the fact that Shepherd did that you know
saying something like you know when you
said you were having a great time that
made me feel like I just discovered
Fibonacci seeds right that's what it's
all about man also rest the boat you
want to get it also rabbits mate and
Fibonacci numbers I'm teaching about
that that's how I'm going to end it or
or or reproduce well the results of
mating okay yeah I'm going to teach them
about sex with Fibonacci we're gonna get
into boats in a second but first we're
gonna talk about merge I've got some
merch on you got some merch on alright
we actually have the same happy Chomper
I've got the happy Chomper on the
striped black-and-white tea link has the
happy Chomper on the handkerchief I
actually forgot this is merged I'm just
now I thought you would have already
called me out on this but well you've
been yeah I saw it you made it you made
a choice in Nashville that you were
gonna be a guy who wears handkerchiefs
on your neck like some sort of outlaw in
this cool I mean I was like you know
what at least I like that interpretation
the outlaw interpretation
bandanna what did he call it
handkerchief well that's a bandit I
would use it as a handkerchief I would
blow my nose into and do I am fully
prepared to defend myself and but you
never went for it so yeah be like me
when you use it as a everything like a
way to like not get germs I'll wipe
everything with it
no I'm saying like you can pull it up
over your you can do like the people do
bandits like a band in the airports yeah
like a bandit at the airport yeah which
is which is totally cool you like that
rapper
what's the rapper Tupac no I don't wear
like Tupac the guy that said the guy
that's popular now that wears the thing
over his face all the time oh I know who
you tell my better don't know his name
get-get your handkerchief on little
something your bandana mythical dot
store get all types of stuff we're just
trying to keep you happy and surprised
and reppin your boys okay boats so link
you you apparently have a list of
different types of boat yeah I assembled
a list and then of every type of boat in
existence and then I I uploaded it to
brand-spanking-new wiki page called list
of boat types this is entirely my work
in alphabetical order so here's the deal
good gracious there's a lot of boats as
I read through I'm not gonna read them
all but I'm just thinking dear ear
biscuit ear maybe one of these boats
will resonate with you you know so that
you'll be able to answer this question
and this is a good conversation for you
to have with people that you want to get
to know better like say you're on a
third date and you're like hey baby
what kind of boat would you be of your
boat this is a good I mean I I think
this is first or second date material
those those kinds of questions those
kinds of introspective questions the
third date I think it's Thursday forced
for us for a first date it's kind of
weird I like you are a therapist I mean
I know I'm a proponent of getting into
get weird are linked to those kinds of
conversations because here's the thing
obviously I'm not in the dating pool if
I were and I ask that question to
someone and they were like I don't I
don't know dump them I'd be like okay
there's nothing to be said okay
you're right I can't stay in this I
can't stand that kind of alright I want
somebody to have a freaking answer for
something all right that's good so this
is a first date question you you're
right yeah hey if you could be a boat
this is how you weed somebody else so
would you if you could be a weed what
kind of weed would you be and if they
say I don't know and that's it if they
say I don't know what what kind of boats
are there well okay that's fine that's
fine what do they say I don't know in
this it's usually saying I don't want
the question they're not I mean I'm not
gonna go on a second date right you
can't poo poo fun esoteric question and
if they say the rockers if they say the
wrong kind of boat there's not gonna be
a second airboat auxilary ship Banana
Boat brig bass boat I'm like a bass boat
and you can't just say because I'm a
redneck no because I'm a fisherman
no it's the functionality of the boat
I'm flat I'm shallow bass boats are
shallow oh you're getting in oh so if
you wanna say so if you want to say why
I'm I'm shallow so I'm a bass boat yeah
I've got I don't know what what else
would it mean about you if you're a bass
boat limited capacity I think first of
all yeah I don't I think just I think
you should go through the boat types
because I think the way that canoe you
interpret the boats like you to such a
shallow that's that's your thing like
for me I wasn't I wasn't thinking in
terms of shallowness but that's that you
can bring it I think they any point of
the question there's no wrong answer
professor punch if she were here she
would be able to tell us but I think
it's just it is what you make I wish she
worked for us maybe that's how it works
once you leave your parents going work
for canoe chundan Vallum not familiar
crash rescue boat this is somebody who
likes to swoop in and save the day or
whenever they're needed yeah you know
they're there
I'm not reading every single boat that I
wrote on this wiki I'm just just what
whichever hits me dengue let's see ferry
so this I think again this is more of
like a facilitator salute like to
people get from point A to point B and
that could be emotionally it could be
metaphysically it could be it could be
physically if you're like a bus driver
and that would be someone who was am I
in my interpretation stuck in a pattern
of only helping people because a ferry
just goes back and forth and back and
forth so on the first codependency can
your date's like I think I'm a ferry
because I'm I'm stuck in a rut of
helping people yeah be like ah no second
date for you are you a dinghy
friendships loop okay well that didn't
know that was a boat but I definitely
that garbage scow I think I know what
that is it's a boat that carries garbage
garbage scow hydrofoil
oh this is technologically advanced if
it it reaches a speed and then it floats
above the water
we're not floats it's like it ascends so
this is like I don't know what kind of
person that would be maybe if you're
like if your head's always in the clouds
I'm stretching here I think it I think
that's I think a hydrofoil might be a
little bit of a show-off oh yeah here I
you can't you just can't you can't
settle for just floating you've got a
levitate you always got to be moving to
inflatable boat Oh
mm-hmm really reliant upon the hot air
of other people oh I think that's you
man I just I've got all my smoke you
just you inflate with it you actually
you blow a lot maybe I'm an inflatable
boat cuz you blow and smoke all the time
I'm talking BS blowing smoke I know I'm
blowing smoke up I'm full of hot air
my human might be which is still the
same thing okay keep going air bag man
got to talk about these a kayak jet boat
lifeboat long boat log boat hmm
I'm skipping one that's gonna be my
answer for later really okay I'm not
looking motorboat naval ship like a big
battleship if you're like if you're
combatant there's a boat called an
optimist which is kind of cheating if
you're like oh well I tend to think of
myself visit if I'm a boat I'm an
optimist yeah that's just no second date
you're short-circuiting the exercise
actually I'm not optimist is a boat and
it's um it's a dinghy also known as the
bathtub is a small single-handed sailing
dinghy yeah what else we've got the
optimist is an optimistic way to call
yourself a dinghy Oh P we've got patrol
boat pirogue or pleasure barge which is
how my wife thinks of me when their
grandma's not looking your grandma is
always looking pleasure craft pontoon
powerboat I don't know what a punt is oh
I know what a punt is because I'm
looking at doing that when I'm in
England it's like it's like a canoe
basically a rowboat and then you stand
in it with a large stick and propel
yourself along the creek
oh really go hunting in the English so
instead of rowing you're pushing off the
bottom mm-hmm well kind I looked at one
picture and that was my interpretation
are you got a riverboat oh you got the
big wheel in the back
steamboat Rodney boat which if your
name's Rodney that's also kind of short
circuiting the exercise here
schooner sea kayak ships tinder skiff
skipjack sloop come on the sloop John B
submarine I don't consider it is a
submarine a boat how do you say it a
submarine where's the B it's underwater
it's like is this a boat talk underwater
submarine try to say words with bees
underwater you won't get funny in a
submarine yeah I've heard of that and
when it's on the surface it's a boat if
you saw a submarine out there floating
would you say hey look at that boat well
they called the German submarines
u-boats and that was a boat it's a boat
it floats torpedo boat trawler tugboat
mmm tugboats I mean that's always
helping people in a jam I feel like I'm
that around you a lot come on let's do
it
let's get going man I don't I don't feel
that way I feel like I might need to be
tugged your grandmother-in-law is
watching man I'm just I'm just saying
like sometimes I'm not motivated it
worked
I know me a tug I know you didn't mean
that as an endo I know that you did not
he know he did not mean the only boat in
that term under V is very slender vessel
yeah okay what dang that's what I pick
for myself what are we doing here okay I
think we should devote an entire podcast
just reading Wikipedia lists yeah that'd
be fun riffing on it and the only one
for Z is Zilly Zilly okay so what what
do you want to do at this point do you
want you you want to tell me what you
think I am and then I'll tell you what I
know and then we'll go into the thing
okay you go first well I'm not gonna be
offended by any well first of all open I
have an open heart let me say a couple
things and just in in you know if--
apology laying the runway for this I
didn't think about this a lot okay no
actually what I learned pretty quickly
is that if you imagine a boat type
almost like a horoscope you can pretty
quickly like find a way to make it match
a person but I think I've got something
that I think is uh what like a jet ski
and a pontoon boat are so different and
they sit I end ok it's this is actually
remarkable that you said
you said both of those okay it's
remarkable that we haven't talked about
this at all and you just said those two
things here's here's here's here's how
what I was I am pretty remarkable um
thank you I think that someone who
doesn't know you well okay and maybe
someone who watch just watches you on
the internet might be like links a jet
ski man a jet ski yep okay but I
actually think you're a pontoon boat
it's hilarious thank you thinking that I
was thinking that you were a pontoon
boat and here's let me explain what
those are like polar opposites you might
be like links to jet ski you never know
is he's nimble he's quick never know
where he's gonna be and boom he's there
a boom he's there and it's and he's a
little flashy
he's always squirting a tiny stream of
water directly into the air right
exactly they all do that right yeah does
it wave runners or what not but I think
that that's actually the reason I don't
think you're a jet ski is because jet
skis change course very quickly you
never know where they're going to be
constantly changing direction changing
course you'll change course and then
it'll take a right and you won't right
and that is not your personality at all
you're you're much more grounded then I
think most people understand assault man
now let me say a couple things about a
pond to boat but I think apply to you
pontoon boats they exist they exist so
people have a good time
Oh like what what is that what I mean
think about you got a pontoon boat it's
like no one looks at a pontoon boat and
is like if people look at a pontoon boat
and they're like well we're gonna have a
good time on that boat yeah like the
purpose of that locally is to get on the
boat and have a party we're gonna slowly
have a good time and I think a lot of
people can be accommodated by that
there's no there's a few things also
about a pontoon boat and that it's it's
actually remarkably stable however it's
got those two big barrels underneath how
when and it happens every so often and
you hear it on the news
yeah when there is a pontoon boat
accident what it's a it's it's bad oh
gosh in the hole and it doesn't it isn't
like a sailboat that you knock it down
and the nut comes back that you a
pontoon boat goes under and everyone
dies what is it what does it mean I
don't know what you're saying you're
saying it if I if something happened to
me a lot of people would go no no I I'm
saying that you are not I you you're
actually you're way more flexible than
you were when we were kids but and
that's and I actually think that this
point in your life you might actually be
more flexible than the average person
are you about to take credit for that
no I do think I do think being married
for a long period of time and also being
in a close friendship business
definitely makes people flexible and so
but you like a pontoon boat is typically
it's on a lake you know what I'm saying
it's like it's like I'm on a lake and I
am this is where the fun is that and I
am happy to be here and you could
potentially I could turn on the motor
and I could get out there into the river
and go into the ocean but you're gonna
have to knock you're gonna have to
convince me to do not really but
practically speaking there's a pontoon
boat it's home is a territory it's
typically lake a lake you know wait
maybe you know you can take them on a
Sounders you know what makes you're not
gonna go out under the surf you know I'm
not trying again there's this isn't a
perfect analogy because I'm not I'm also
not saying that you're not adventurous
but your general disposition tends to be
like you know what if I can if if I can
stay at home this weekend and clean my
garage that's what I'm gonna do
yeah I don't want to react too much
because I have a different answer but
there are is a lot of overlap and so I'd
like to come back to the pontoon boat
okay and see how it works with what I
think what will my answer for myself is
okay I think my answer for you is the
answer that you have in your own brain
for yourself right now okay I think that
you are thinking and I too am thinking
of you as a sailboat hmm now I think
first of all just because whenever you
are thinking about boats I think the
first thing you're gonna think about is
a sailboat you have this imagined
aspirational love affair with the idea
of sailing true we've talked about this
right you may have even we may have even
established it as a what you call a
layer and I call a phase which we have
discussed at length and an earlier ear
biscuit that you can go back and listen
to if you want to I mean you have a you
know if you pass a sailing book you're
gonna pick it up if you pass the sailing
channel on YouTube you're gonna watch it
true yeah so I I think that's the first
thing you thought and then you're
motivated to make that describe you
because again like you said it getting
this guy very interesting but then if
I'm gonna I'm like I actually think this
could work because a sailboat is if you
think of like adventurous new thing you
know I think and I and there's like a
you put in that you have to put in the
work when you're sailing it's it you
just can't lay back and troll around you
can't just crank it up and steer it is
my understanding there's a sail involved
got a lot of work and like like a lot of
research like the the fact the fact that
you would research the Fibonacci
sequence and then be angry at yourself
that you hadn't done it before now you
felt the need to like state publicly
you're embarrassed by that is I think
this dynamic of you want to be able to
say okay this being an accomplished
sailor require something I think I'm by
the way I think
just making an argument why you want to
be a sailor not know what your
personality is right it's about the boat
man say someone who sails needs to put
in a lot of work and then the fruits of
that labor is that they can experience
something new and I do think that the
work that you put into things is always
motivated by experiencing something new
and I've I think we it's well documented
that the work that I put into things is
to is to make something better or to
make a situation better or to make the
situation by in contrast to more more
secure more right use this to to achieve
or experience something new so like
sailing is like what's the next harbour
right what's the next what's the next
adventure what's around the next
Peninsula so I and there's also a lot of
would you like wood yeah I got would you
like it um a lot of wood is sailboat so
again I'm making more of an argument
that you really like sailboats but I do
think that it could apply and I think
that's what you're gonna build on when
you say that your answer is to sailboat
okay so do you want to you want to
respond to what I said about I don't
want to I kind of want to just go with
it just say sailboat okay am i right
you're not well you're half right here's
what you're half right what's half a
sailboat a boat that is sinking my first
thought was sailboat of course yeah and
I'm right about that upon further review
i I thought I want to be a sailboat but
I actually don't think that I quite am
mm-hmm so what you said about like you
know and I didn't and I you know I tend
to like embrace a new adventure travel
like I'm using this as an analogy
like move into something new and unknown
and going through unknown potentially
uncharted dangerous waters to get there
like that's my lifeblood like I I
absolutely love and it implies
achievement that's the other part yeah
and one that I think drives you and that
is yeah I'm you know we thought about it
we haven't done the podcast yet but I am
in Enneagram 3 and so I I'm a performer
I'm an achiever and I'm largely driven
by accomplishment to to my benefit and
to my demise at times but the one thing
that I don't think applies to me with
the sailboat is that a sailboat is well
and I also tend to thing I think I think
of myself as pretty resilient
like being able to write myself and that
kind of thing and in storms and that
kind of thing but sailboat is very
reliant it's but by definition it is not
self propelled it is you got to you got
to get the winds got to come along and I
actually think that I'm actually a
little bit less resilient than a
sailboat and I'm significantly more self
propelled than the cell boat I actually
think I'm a I'm gonna use the qualifier
cheap yacht and this is why I say that
so in some ways like a yacht like a
powerboat that's made to go long
distances so embraces adventure it will
it can get you to the same places that a
sailboat can not quite as sure of a
thing as a sailboat because you again
you're under your own power not quite as
it doesn't have the same ability to
write itself yachts tend to be a little
bit depending on and I say cheap because
you know you've got you go and you go to
like a seaside town and you go to the
harbour and you see everybody's got
their boats and they got their yachts
and there's big yachts there's a little
yachts or yachts in between and you've
got like the like CEO yacht which is
this really expensive
magnificent yacht that's got like a
helicopter pad on it I'm not that I'm
like the guy who just got got together
money and went in debt to get this boat
that kind of it looks like it could
belong in a harbor but it's posing a
little bit okay but I think that the
self-propelled nature of it so you're
you're you're you're a self-reliant
poseur well and I just because you know
and it's funny because I it's
interesting you know as you like you
talk about your kids not and I look at
my kids and you see qualities from
yourself and your kids and qualities
from your your partner and your kids and
like Locke is is like really just
self-motivated right like he'd like once
he got in his mind he wanted to play
basketball or make good grades or you
know like he's he's learning a language
in school and then he's learning a
language on his own and he's like well
because learning a language is like so
good for your brain you like has I hear
myself yeah
when he goes into these explanations but
it's almost like it's intensified
because jesse is also very
self-motivated so it's almost like it's
very intensified in him you kind of like
reflect back on yourself but and again I
think that I don't always think this is
a good thing I think that like you said
I don't die I shouldn't feel any shame
or embarrassment embarrassment for not
knowing what the Fibonacci numbers are
but I have a dual motivation for knowing
them part it's part genuine interest in
a genuine curiosity because it's like
this is a reality that exists in our
universe that is this fundamental thing
that can be observed in all these
different ways and it's like it feels
significant it feels like I'd be missing
out if I didn't understand it but then
the other half is I want to be able to
talk about it I want to be able to tell
someone about it so that I will seem
smart you know I have to I have to fight
against that Tennessee kind of like when
a cheap yacht pulls up next to like a
exact tune exactly it's like starts
filling his ear full of stuff well and
that's just
Battle of the India gram 3 is like
there's there's a lot of good that can
come from that personality but then you
can actually get very caught up in your
your own stuff you know and you know
believe your own what is it what is the
this the the phrase smell your own or
something
what is he I've never heard that I've
done it but I've never heard it you know
what I'm saying so anyway I think I'm a
cheap yacht cheap yacht because you're
self-motivated and you still like to go
a lot of places and I suffer from
imposter syndrome I think that's where
the cheap yacht comes in is that I do we
do a lot of different things we have the
privilege of doing a lot of different
things we talked about a little bit like
playing at the Ryman like there's many
times that we get to do things and I
suffer from heavy doses of imposter
syndrome where I'm like I shouldn't be
here like I'm not like I'm just dude
that can you know write a funny song and
convince people that I've got some time
we got way too many balls jokes to be at
this right the yeah so I think that's
where the cheap part comes a high Church
of country music
yeah that's what I call it the high
Church of country music miss know what
it's actually go what's it called the
mother tree Mother Church okay Who am I
to critique that you know there's no
wrong answers right yeah that's cool
insight that if we were on our first
date I'd be like oh no second date here
okay shall I talk about show my boat
well you know I did think it but that
the backdrop to my thought process was
Chrissy and I were talking about one of
the contributing factors to the health
of our marriage 19 years at and I was
like you know I just think for us the
compatibility like the core
compatibility that we had we it's like
we have we've changed a lot and yeah
we've we've changed together even though
so at every turn you don't have to you
know you know who knows how you you
can't control exactly the person you
become we're very fortunate that you
know we've changed in a parallel path
mm-hmm but I think a lot of it has to do
with that that that core compatibility
which I kind of boiled down to we both
really place a high value on comfort and
security like there's a like and so it
motivates us so much that yet you're
exactly right when I say like when I'm
given an opportunity of like you want to
travel anywhere on the globe next
weekend or you want to just stay at home
and reclaim your garage and it's that's
not an easy decision you know it's like
a it it it's I'm not saying it's
automatic but I'm saying that's a
difficult decision for me and Christy
and it's like that could be a big source
of conflict if somebody never wants to
reclaim their garage you know so we have
like we got a same we got the same
instinct when it comes to those things
and so I I was that conversation is kind
of coloring my boat äj-- and so yeah I
definitely thought about a pontoon boat
because I was thinking about a jet ski
versus a pontoon boat and how like jet
skis like all about fun but a pontoon
boat is still about they're still fun
want a lot of fun it's a party boat but
it's very it's very it's a controlled
fun like there is a control element to
like I have a vision for how I think
things should be and my motivation is
usually pretty pure in like oh I want I
want to have fun when people have fun
with people to enjoy the Misses
experience love beat himselves that type
of stuff and then I moved on to well I
don't I don't know if I'm a pontoon boat
I think I might be I placed such a value
on things be
like my space being nested and like the
way that I want it like my home is such
a haven to me I'm like I think I might
be a houseboat hmm okay and like I was
kind of curious because you know jesse
has such a vision for how she wants your
house to look and I feel like you it
it's much that's weighted much more
towards her and it is for me and Christy
to like she's she's very talented at
decorating and does our house and stuff
and all that stuff but I'm very much
involved in like I in everything because
I want it to be how I want it to be from
a practical standpoint like I take so
much joy in knowing that everything's
where I want it to be in the garage or
like that our backyard works in this way
or I want to be able to sit here and see
this while doing this and listening to
this music and like put a lot of work
into that into my house so that's when I
started to think yeah could be a
houseboat but I think I'm a a yacht
I actually I settled on in the brief
amount of time that I thought about this
I actually said it on and I ain't even
talking about like a two-bit yacht we
both have said yachts for ourselves
my answer is frickin yacht and I I went
all the way to like helicopter pad and
everything because I place an
overemphasis on my environment being
exactly how I want it to be in a as
luxurious as it can be like I want my
life to be engineered not not for my
pleasure alone but for for my comfort
and security you know so that that's
when I thought about a yacht I guess I
guess it may be but maybe it's a pontoon
yacht I do like to go places I like the
experience adventure but I had
but it has to be much more on my terms
then I think your yours would be I
didn't think about like being a my and
my self-motivated I didn't enter in my
equation or anything I can see that
comfort insecurity
like I want to I want to I want to yacht
with a chef well maybe you're like a
yacht security detail you're a yacht
unlike the Great Lakes yeah I'm saying
the Great Lakes can get you can't see
the other side are their yachts on the
Great Lakes yeah yeah are you seeing how
big they are look at a map man they're
massive yeah I've never looked in the
squall on the Great Lakes to Chicago
I've seen the great lake at Chicago yeah
I don't yeah I opened the door and it
just blasts and also a yacht is a pretty
broad incidentally a very broad term I
mean like I don't know what the
technical definition of it is but it
does it is one of the more flexible
terms for boats so it doesn't surprise
me that for different reasons we ended
up there I mean I think that yeah I
could probably just go back to settling
on houseboat cuz I think that does I've
never been on a houseboat but I'm a
madman I spend an evening on one really
a weekend well I imagine them being if
you're gonna live there they better be
how you want them to be you know yeah as
opposed to I can I can endure this for
until we get to like if we get through
the squall walking back to the well you
know it's interesting and this is
another I this is another show I want to
do I was talking to you about this
because you talk about like making these
decisions and getting things the way
that you want yeah and the way that I
relate to that because we're all so
we're like we're basically redoing our
homes in you know similar amounts of
change like you guys have done more
already but like I'm redoing my whole
backyard this summer and we've redone
like there's a bathroom inside you guys
just finished a bathroom you know
there's there's renovations that we
treated our kitchen that kind of thing
and my involvement is very much like
aesthetically I don't like I care but I
also know that if Jessie narrows it down
to five different options for tile
they're all gonna be they're all gonna
be great so it's like she's showing them
to me she they've already gotten through
so many levels of discretion that I'm
just like just make the decision like
I'm not particular I want it to be cool
and I want it to be I want it to look
good but I know that it will be if you
do it and so I don't I'm not particular
so I'm not gonna make I do what I do is
I say I care about like a few practical
things not to the level of detail
anywhere close to the level of detail
that you do but I but I like okay
where's the grill gonna go it's like
okay I'm gonna go out there this is
important I'm gonna use this thing I'm
gonna be the man at the grill I want to
think about what kind of grill it's
gonna be and I'll get really excited
about the specific type of grill and
where it is but then it's not it's not
gonna go much deeper than deeper than
that and I think you know I think about
the well I think it was Oh what I want
to say is the the episode that I wanted
to do was is we're both in the market
for to get a new vehicle you can get a
boat that drives on land I think and I'm
fascinated with differences in the way
that we make that decision oh so you're
talking about surrounding yourself with
luxury and getting things the way you
want but the decision to get a new car
has been one that has I mean it I'm not
gonna get into it because I think
there's a whole episode we can save that
but it's interesting because we gonna
have a boat episode and a car episode
well but transportation series but a
boat episode is not like what kind of
boat am I gonna buy because that's like
the next level douche yeah okay but if
it's just like what kind of car am I
gonna buy we're just kind of private
plane and mine we could get into some
douche douchiness in that conversation
but I just it's I think it's again it's
very revealing about the nature
personalities in the way that we make
decisions about those kinds of things
but the way that we both candid up kind
of landing on yacht that's funny
I think that means that we can we should
go in on a yacht huh
with the I guess would like a hundred
other people how many people yeah yeah
sure
yeah can you do that I think that's I'm
much more interested in like getting a
yacht that I'm about more introspection
at this point so let's let's continue
our own conversation that way but I'll
open it up hashtag ear biscuits let us
know what boat you think you are and if
you're on a first date and you're
listening to this you don't listen to us
during the first date I mean yeah that
would be weird
I mean but I do recommend that you
recommend us to anyone you're dating but
if somebody and listen separately so we
get twice the listen that somebody asks
you to listen to a podcast on the first
date that is a red flag even if it's
this one yeah
but let's make an exception for hours
maybe a portion of any other cast but a
podcast is like typically like an hour
of just listening to other people how is
that different than going to a movie
all right let's save that to let's say
we got an official episode about first
dates you shouldn't go to a movie on the
first date that's a red flag
you go what are you gonna learn about
somebody sitting next to them looking at
a screen nothing if you if you watch a
movie and you talk about it but I don't
know I don't yeah that's the hot take
that's harsh take okay hashtag your
biscuits let us know what kind of boat
you are and why or what kind of boat
someone you're dating said they were and
why let's make a recommendation is it my
turn yep I got to go back to music
because here's the thing
nothing is more exhilarating than what
it probably is I got a backtrack already
but I love the exhilaration associated
with discovering an artist and then
realizing they got a whole backlog of
material so it's not like the
horses in the back guy you look at him
on Spotify that's the only song he's got
well you got the remix with Billy Ray
Cyrus yeah pretty limited I'm not
recommending that I'm not painting it
either though but when you look on
Spotify you'll you find something
somewhere and then you're like whoa
there's some albums like I could get
like a deep dive let's do it and then
when you like the song and then you you
click over to the wiki because you like
knowing a little bit about the backstory
and you realize that this artist it
described as a virtuoso violinist who
then is also well known as a Whistler
what he's a virtuoso violinist and a
virtuosic virtual virtue a statistic
mm-hmm yeah whistler at the same time
could be yeah he can sing and play the
violin at the same time and he's got a
he's got a number of instrumental albums
how did you find one is called Canyon
and when it's called River and I think
at least with the canyon one maybe with
both he would take his violin and he
would play in that location wasn't in
Utah ain't telling you yet man I'm
building it up oh say you want it so bad
but you can't get it yeah I wouldn't say
one of that bad and he's he takes his
violin and he does these looping and
layering parts it's it's amazing but
that's just instrumental stuff and then
his brand-new album that just came out
I'm like this sounds like the guy who
father John misty has been impersonating
I mean he's got that sound so I'm just
joking I I'm I'm sorry father John I I'd
like to be your friend I'm not saying
you impersonate him so he sings as well
he sings oh it's not all whistling
because that would get old right so he
is a he is a lyricist and a vocalist and
a touring musician and his name is
Andrew bird
dude is awesome Andrew bird yeah
shout-out to Andrew bird check out his
songs Sisyphus he's got a whistling part
in that and it's one thing to hear the
whistle but then it's another thing to
watch him on his Instagram perform it
live and he just effortlessly goes into
this like immaculate whistle I give a
lot to whistle well I can't whistle man
you can't whistle at all you can make
yourself an instrument at any time I've
like I can hit like two notes I can
whistle like this - this is highs I can
get that's a tongue whistle you didn't
go like a teakettle
you know I'm saying I got one limited
rain no I can't use it you took away my
whistle yep I can't do the fingers in
the mouth whistle that's a big dad play
yeah we got to work on that so there it
is Andrew bird check him out shouts outs
to the man with the whistle with the go
ordering whistle okay all right let's um
let's start searching up some some yards
man let's see how much it maybe we
should just I mean that's just rent yeah
just going on pontoon boat first like
chase said he went to a wedding this
past weekend on a yacht well you
remember I wanted to have my birthday
party on a yacht a yacht rock band and
then I didn't have and then I look into
the price yeah and that's an indication
you will not be purchasing me on to
watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]